anthony colette et rythmé tonnerre donc
son danseur réel ça y est ça c'est pécho
jeter passée sur un catch à ses basques
sur une rumba s'est passé rue sur une
salsa mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que ça dansait sec voyait ça se
voyait vous aussi vous avez vu servi et
bien sûr ah ouais savez tous d'avancer
alors je vous dis au monde a fait un
petit vidéo récap et donc ça confirme
que vraiment ça se pécho dans danse avec
les stars
l'adage est au mauvais endroit en droit
je le chroniqueur en garde
on le sait dans la danse la complicité
avec son partenaire est essentiel et sa
iris ménard l'a bien compris cette
saison la jeune femme participe à danse
avec les stars sur tf1 une aventure
qu'elle compte bien gagner comme tous
les concours auxquels elle participe
miss nord
et c'est aux côtés du danseur ans toni
collette qu'elle s'entraîne chaque
semaine
et d'après les rumeurs entre les deux
danseurs la complicité serait plus forte
que jamais le duo seraient devenus
inséparables dans la vie comme sur la
piste
la semaine dernière on découvrait dans
dalsky rice avait invité le danseur à
lille pour lui présenter sa maman et
selon public les deux complices seraient
même plus qu'à me ils seraient en couple
iris et anthony passerait toutes leurs
soirées ensemble comme ici dans les
gradins du stade de france si c'est le
cas ce n'est pas la première fois qu'un
tel cas de figure arrive dans l'émission
on te souviens par exemple de grégoire
lyonnet et alizée toujours en couple et
même marié et c'est vrai d'ailleurs
lundi on fera une spéciale coupe dans
danse avec les stars parce que et on a
les infos là ça serait chaud dans tous
les sens alors mais je vous le dis c'est
devenu n'importe quoi cette émission ça
fait rire encore vous avez encore plus
envie de le faire ah ben non moi je ne
te cache y avait une bonne janvier va
pas faire dans sa quête alors je vous le
dis moi j'ai même des amis des fois
qu'ils ont leur meuf qui vont faire dans
un sac et ça ils choisissent eux-mêmes
le danseur mon angoisse parce que ça se
chope à touba oui mais vous savez que ça
pose d'énormes problèmes parce que ça
crée des jalousies
parce qu'évidemment on sait très bien
que ce couple là qui va être largement
exposé va faire du buzz pour l'émission
d'un sûr qu'ils vont rester encore plus
longtemps